broken bones and fractures are some of
the injuries in this pediatric
orthopedic Ward Frey Hospital in East
London like many public health
institutions in South Africa is
struggling the waiting list for surgery
can take years because of Staff
shortages equipment and money
it's in the Eastern Cape one of the
poorest provinces in the country more
than 90 percent of the 6.7 million
people of the Eastern Cape it depends on
public health care because they are
uninsured they don't have medical AIDS
so
we are just delivering this service and
we are not able to
generate any income
so it's quite a steep a
Hill to climb most people in here can't
afford to pay for treatment they rely on
publicly funded hospitals which charge a
small fee and are often overstretched
the provincial Health Department owes
millions in outstanding payments to some
service providers Healthcare in South
Africa is sharply divided between the
Haves and the have-nots the rich go to
private hospitals that are some of the
best facilities on the African continent
the poor majority can only access the
overburdened public health system
people hoping to get help at smaller
community health centers and Clinics
face similar challenges including low
staff morale Benicia Clinic my
appointment at the clinic was for half
past two the security guard at the gate
said there are no nurses and I should go
home I am worried because my child needs
to be vaccinated
the governing African National Congress
plans to introduce a universal
healthcare scheme the proposed plan will
be funded by pulling together public and
private resources critics of the
government worry corruption and
mismanagement could delay implementing
the healthcare scheme that means
ensuring citizens have access to Quality
Health Care in one of the world's most
unequal societies may still take some
time
haramutasa Al Jazeera East London South
Africa
actor Michael Gambon famed for playing
dumb
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera